[Musique]
vous les attendez chaque semaine avec
impatience les résultats sportifs du
week end avec michael et demi d'euros
bonsoir bonsoir l'actualité sportive
toujours très chargé avec une météo
aussi capricieuse en ce week end michael
on commence avec du football c'est sa
direction le championnat de régionale 3
1 but a suffi à leur bonheur le strap
assuré l'essentiel ce dimanche 10
février en s'imposant sur la plus petite
des marges 1-0 à domicile face à pas
résident dans une rencontre marquée hoyé
but par des incidents
magnifique magnifique volée par les
incidents en fin de partie les
conditions climatiques difficiles mettra
pas résisté à la tempête sur le terrain
dans les coûts de direction micro de
mélanie copie on a réussi à développer
un jeu assez peu orthodoxes ont bondi
parce que les terrains ne permettait pas
trop mais ça a été le but il nous a
vraiment libérés du coup après on a
essayé de poser la balle pour jouer un
match engagé puisque un terrain à la
limite du praticable mais un bon match
dans l'ensemble on a on a su respecter
les consignes qui était donné une
victoire 1 0 qui me semble mérité cette
victoire était également importante sur
le plan comptable grégory ce résultat
permet à trappes de conserver son avance
sur son adversaire du jour
c'est assez serré au niveau des points
c'était un concurrent direct c'est avec
cette victoire et on les met à cinq
points derrière nous du coup ça nous
soulage et ça me retire à concurrents
pour le titre
à neuf journées de la fin du championnat
trap est toujours invaincu avec la
meilleure défense l'équipe pointe à la
deuxième place de régionale 3 après le
football du football américain
les templiers d'elancourt ont enregistré
leur troisième victoire en trois matches
dans le championnat de deuxième division
les élans courtois se sont imposés
samedi soir à domicile face aux myrmidon
de savigny-le-temple le score 26 à 7 une
victoire qui leur permet de prendre la
tête de la poule b de la conférence nord
on écoute le président des templiers
d'elancourt joël da silva pour un match
de trois victoires donc pour l'instant
on est dans net sur les objectifs fixés
qui est de se câliner dans un premier
temps pour les play-offs
donc pour l'instant tous en tout ça
tout s'emboîte correctement la semaine
prochaine on va villeneuve d'ascq et les
vikings de guilde donc voilà pour
l'heure son tour tout est en ordre de
marche et on termine par du rugby dans
le championnat honneur versailles n'en
finit plus de gagner 13ème victoire en
13 matches pour les versets qui se sont
cette fois ci imposé dans la douleur sur
le terrain du rc paris 15 le score 15 à
11 pour les joueurs de la cité royale
qui reste en tête du classement avec
écoutez moi bien grégory à 21 points
d'avancé sur le second autant dire que
la montée n'est plus très loin beaucoup
de points d'avancé merci michael plus de
résultats de reportage à suivre dans
l'émission le 7-8 force est à retrouver
dans quelques instants sur tv 78 3